adam with you
raising uh these twins like you grew up
not rich
you've kind of faced adversity and had
to work real hard to get out of that
situation but now you're raising kids
presumably with less adversity like how
do you kind of address that as a parent
um you know i i i it'd be hard to
impose a bunch of gravity on my kids the
kind of gravity that i grew up in
it would just be bizarre to try to
withhold [ __ ] from them um
so basically my head on it is
i'm not i'm not stern or strict you know
i i'm not one of these parents that's
like
you know i grew up poor and now you're
rich but you're gonna have to learn all
the virtues of being poor and working
hard and all that
i i basically i'm laissez faire with all
that [ __ ]
my my thing with my kids
and i felt this way growing up but in a
more negative way
which is you know instead of parents
kind of imposing a bunch of rules and
regulations
and here's here's the way we're going to
do it i
try all the time to just sort of lead by
example
you know i just say you know i would i
would leave
when the comedy clubs were open
um i would go out two or three nights a
week
to just go do comedy for free like i'd
go the comedy store on a saturday night
and and i would say to my son and my
daughter like
saturday night i'd i'd say look
uh you know we live pretty far away from
the comedy store
and i would say i'm going out i'm not
getting paid
i'm doing it so i can get better at
stand-up comedy
and i'm leaving now and i won't be back
till midnight
but that's what i'm choosing to do and
even though i have money and even though
i'm successful
it's important that i go out and try to
get better
at this craft and they they would tell
me i'm blocking the tv set and hit the
road
what i made my statement yeah well okay
that's good
that's right [ __ ] a cocktail waitress
did a 10-minute set
and we came home
yeah dude